he is the quarterback of the cincinnati
bearcats what a season they had and now
he is fresh off of the nfl scouting
combine joining us on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line is quarterback desmond
ritter how are you desmond
i'm doing well how are you thanks for
having me thank you for coming on what
uh what'd you make of the combine what'd
you think uh yeah i thought it was a a
great experience for me to go out there
and um kind of show what i could do but
you know overall the experience was fun
give me good to get around a lot of the
competitors um and then a lot of the
other position groups as well
but then also to meet around all the
coaching styles again um it was a great
experience all right so give me the
typical day that didn't involve on-field
drills you mean so give me what what was
your wednesday like because you did your
thursday night on field drills i want
people to know how how crazy it is for
for for prospects folks like yourself
give me your wednesday
so wednesday was a medical day
we woke up had uh just general medical
information
for about an hour and a half what time
did you wake up what was your wake up
what what was the alarm that day was
about 5 45.
are you an early morning riser you're a
college kid but you're in early are you
an early morning riser
yeah i just got to get out once i get up
i'm good to go
well wait a minute dude do you have a
baby right do you have a kid yeah yeah
oh what a silly question then so of
course you're annoying okay yeah it's
easier for me so this is a vacation wait
a minute this is a vacation for you the
combine yes some of these some of these
times we're sleeping all the way through
the night is good
okay i'm ready to interrupt so keep
going what your wednesday was like go
for it yeah no so then we did general
medical information for about an hour
and a half um and then we went straight
to where it was
on medical for for all the team
evaluation so you would walk into a room
um with your main doctor who evaluated
you real quick um then that doctor would
go and present to about six or seven
teams um and you do like a rotation of
about six rooms yeah um so once once all
the doctors involve you and ask all the
questions they need to ask which took
about another hour and a half um then
you go do um your mris your x-rays your
cts your body scans um and that could
take anywhere from you know just an hour
all the way to
five six hours
it took about three and a half hours
um and then i was able to get some
dinner or excuse me from launch around
like one o'clock 2 30 um and then i went
to do the the photo shoot with all the
cool graphics and everything that you
see on tv i love the espn or or nfl
network that's the one um yeah and then
um
you know then after that we did a couple
of interviews
then got some dinners and then we have
meetings um and those last from about
eight to eleven
and so you're basically on you know the
whole day and then the next day you had
a workout
yeah then the next day you gotta get up
and go put on your best physical
performance so you know it it's a lot
from you uh not only mentally but but it
sounds physically draining as well wow
okay so um how many teams did you meet
with desmond ritter how many teams yeah
so so i met with you know there were
there were 18 slots uh the first day we
we just did informal team our formal
teams excuse me that was on tuesday and
then on wednesday
we did informals which was kind of a big
room they call the train station um you
just go down there and teams will come
and pick from you and talk to you for 15
20 minutes
so that the first day i met with nine um
and then the second day i met with
another nine but uh i think only a
couple were the same okay um
which teams do you meet with you want to
throw some out here for me go somewhere
yeah
[Music]
you know a handful of other teams
hmm what was the strangest question you
got to ask desmond rigger
uh i never really got any i asked very
many strange questions but the only odd
thing that i think you guys know by now
is um when we walked into philadelphia
um into their meeting room they made us
shoot them a little tight school so
that was the only thing that really
threw me off real quick so they again
they made you shoot little free throws
like my my uh
my friend here chris brockman's son cage
shoots on it um so he would be did you
know that your son is preparing for the
combine interviews no idea okay yeah so
how how did you how did you perform
desmond how did you perform
so i made my first one and then the the
next two left a couple short um hit the
fourth one and missed the fifth one so i
went two for five so the pressure is is
is on or where some of your other your
your combine mates there as well or just
you and siriani and howie roseman and
the rest of the eagles
uh yeah it's just me and the whole
coaching staff and you know some of the
owners and gm's but it's just you you
know that's the first thing they did as
soon as you walk into the room alright
put your stuff down
i shoot five shots behind the yellow
tape
so i got back there and thought i'd put
enough shots up for this offseason to be
able to to make more than two but i
guess not
so uh desmond ritter here on the rich
eisen show uh i asked this interestingly
enough of jalen hurts now the eagles uh
when he was going through i'll ask you
uh what will a team get if they draft
desmond ritter
yeah i think uh first and foremost for
super bowl um because i'm a winner and
two because i'm a competitor i'm gonna
do anything it takes to win
um and then they're also just gonna get
a hard-working loyal guy
one who's gonna love you know whatever
city he goes to uh make sure to leave my
name there as a mark for the good
and um you know just like i said a
competitor a go-getter a winner
and so um this year
um proving that that you got to a
national championship semifinal game
what
what growth did you experience this year
in your estimation
for yeah
i feel like it was more off the field in
my preparation that's where i felt like
i took the next step um and that's part
of the reasons why i came back from my
decision to come back after the 2020
season
was i felt you know at that time i was
just doing what every other college
quarterback was doing um and you know
for me to take that next step i just
needed to take a step forward like how
so like what what do you mean like what
exactly did you did you do yeah yeah so
as far as preparation you know i was
able to you know be in the offensive
staff room with all the coaches to go
over our game planning um every single
week for every game um so on sunday
nights i was in there until about 10 30
11 um and then on our day off on mondays
i would get up get in there around 6 30
and we would game plan 11 personnel on
mondays and then tuesdays we're third
down in red zone days you know after we
practice go back up in there
and get all that together and then on
tuesday through through game day you
know as soon as the practice is over
with everyone's showers got treatment
got something to eat in them you know i
would host meetings um with some of my
teammates you know just to go over that
day's practice film um to make sure that
that everything's right
desmond ritter here on the rich eisen
show and then off the field as well you
again you have
you have a girl you've got a daughter
huh yeah yeah baby girl my baby girl
how so how old is she
she's uh she's about to be 11 months on
the 19th so we're we're playing our
one-year-old birthday party right now so
times are exciting around the house
so how does one
man
how how does one prepare to be drafted
and go through all of this and train and
combine
with an 11 month old
yeah you know fortunate enough for me i
have a wonderful mother my child and
girlfriend um who does a heck of a job
with her uh you know all these times
when i'm not lifting out of the way
she's been able to be home and be with
our daughter and help her grow
um so you know i got all that going on
and all the football life going on um
and then it's always great to come home
and see my daughter that's claire right
that's you yeah okay yeah and did you
met you've known her you met her a long
time ago right you're like uh high
school sweethearts or something like
that yeah i met her freshman year um of
high school
a mutual friend on the on the football
team they lived next to each other um
and then it was we started dating junior
here
i got to tell you man i mean did do you
do you mention this in meetings do they
ask you about it because you're
obviously further along the line in
terms of life and maturity than than
maybe some others that uh you will be
compared and contrast with in in the
draft desmond yeah right yeah i would
say yes some of them some of them do
some of them don't um someone will will
leave it out you know who are you
bringing with you if we were to draft
you uh and then others you know just
dive into it kind of how we just did of
you know how do you how do you
differentiate um you know life is being
a father in life as being a football
player and a quarterback at that and
then you know what are the similarities
what are the differences between the two
um so you know just simple things like
that um but yeah okay desmond ritter
here on the rich eisen show a couple
more minutes left with you sir so
um
do you think cincinnati gets a bad rap
in college football because what aac and
and nobody really uh yeah because i mean
it seemed like there some people thought
others deserved a shot against alabama
not you i'll give you the floor on that
one desmond yeah um it's easy for for
the outside world to say but um i bet
you they wouldn't be saying that you
know it's us cincinnati lined up against
one of our teams um and they went out
there and played them because you know
it probably ended up in a cincinnati w
but we don't have to say much more than
that other than uh them boys are going
to keep working to to be the best no
matter what anyone says about them and
um i i enjoyed meeting for brief bit
sauce
this past weekend as well
seems like there's very few people on
your team uh short of confidence desmond
ritter yeah
yeah no he's the guy who came in from
day one um with all that confidence
and you know we kind of looked at him
crazy and then and then he earned it
to be able to go out there and just be
the way that he is so you know he had he
had a great weekend and uh
you know had himself uh had himself a
good couple of days yeah i i'll bite on
that one hold on a minute i'll bite on
that one what do you mean looked at him
a little
crazy i mean
because you know he came in here as a
17 year old freshman
about six four probably around 160
um and you know he told him he was like
i'm sorry
excuse me what
and he was like yeah call me sauce and
we were all like you know us older guys
were like uh no we're not we're not
gonna walk around here calling you sauce
like what's your real name again he's
like ahmad alright we'll call you a mod
um and then you know he earned that
nickname over his couple of years i was
about to say so at what point did you
say all right sauce i i hear you when
did that happen yeah
no it was it was after um the first
season more so after the uh the ucf game
at home um when he got it his first
career paid six i think it was um that
helped us and we were like okay you
might have something here
i love that it was like we are not
calling you sauce but it does take some
serious you know gumption to introduce
yourself as such to a whole bunch of
people when you're 17. right yeah i mean
but you know that's that's the
confidence he's had like we said ever
since he's been you know a young kid a
young adult um and it's just going to
keep continuing to carry with him so uh
before i let you go what is your plan
between now and drafting what do we got
uh yeah i'm already back out here in
california you know just kind of this
kind of phone call was almost in the
middle of the workout but we got the
workout just over with um so um you know
working out getting uh physical training
pt on physical therapy and uh you know
just working out staying in shape
getting ready for pro day okay and when
is your pro day again when's that march
march 24th okay march 24th back in
cincinnati um for your i guess your
cincinnati if you will uh finale
uh and then where are you going to be
for draft you're going to be worried
what do you got
yeah for drafts i'll either be um in
vegas if i get to invite or back home in
louisville
um with a whole bunch of friends and
family so i love it well good for you uh
great combine you look great you really
did yes sir thank you thank you you did
and um you know i guess the only thing
that you didn't do um stupendously well
was uh three uh little tike free throws
that uh unfortunately
you shorted them um other than that
you look back and you know those might
have been the the three you know
so-called throws that you i wanted to
get back
no it's all right you know you didn't
expect it and and other than that
congratulations on everything and uh
let's continue to stay in touch thanks
for the call yes sir yes sir thank you
for having me you got it that's desmond
ritter of cincinnati bearcat football
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here